字幕: Harue Mori
校正: Hiroko Kawano
あなたは ３分で作ることができる
カップラーメンを
１分で作れと言われたら
何を考えるでしょうか？
「そんなの無理だ 諦めよう」
と思うのでしょうか？
それとも「何とか知恵を振り絞って
１分で完成させよう」と考えるでしょうか？
僕たちラグビー部は
週３回 １回の練習は最大90分
夏休みは１週間の合宿のみの
練習しかありません
つまり 僕たちの練習時間は
カップラーメンを１分で作れと
言われているのと同じ状況なのです
しかし 僕たちはこれまで
５度の静岡県チャンピオンになり
全国大会に出場しました
なぜ僕たちが そんなことを
成し遂げることができたのか
そのカギは２つあります
いかにその１分間を工夫して
効率的に行動するか と
残りの２分をどのように使うかです
今日は部活動を通じて僕たちが学んだ
今 自分たちが置かれた環境についての
考え方を 皆さんにお伝えしたいと思います
部活動の練習は週３日
１回は最大90分であるというのは
文武両道を目指すために
学校創立当初から
ラグビー部だけでなく
全ての部活動共通で決められたことです
しかしそこには 僕たちにとって
様々な不都合があります
それでも僕たちは この１分間の中で
なんとか美味しいカップラーメンを食べたい
だから 僕たちはこの１分間を工夫して
僕たちはこの１分間を大切にし
工夫することで
より中身の濃いものにしています
この取り組みの中から 代表的な実践例と
その狙いをお話しします
全国的な部活動の練習時間と比べると
僕たちの練習時間は短いです
そこで先ほどの １分間で作り上げるという
カップラーメンの原理を使います
僕たちは練習時間中に 練習メニューの内容を
確認する時間が確保できません
ですから 火曜 木曜 土曜日の朝に
ラグビー部員のみでミーティングを行い
ここで その日の
練習メニューを発表します
あらかじめ練習メニューを
発表しておくことで
全員が その練習メニューにおいて
意識するべきポイントを 認識した状態で
練習に入ることができます
そして 僕たち部員
みんなが集まる貴重な時間を
ひとりでもできる
坂ダッシュ 走り込みなど
体力づくりをする時間に
使ってしまってはもったいないと考え
練習中に走り込みはしません
その代わりに １回の練習で
約10回ある給水の時間を
ダッシュの時間として
有効活用しています
こちらがその映像です
［水までダッシュ］
（映像内の掛け声）水！
さらに 僕たちラグビー部では
ラグビーに対する意識や知識に
まだまだギャップがあります
ラグビーに対する意識がバラバラでは
試合はおろか 短い練習でさえも
成り立ちません
そこで「意思統一ミーティング」という
ビデオミーティングを行い
練習中確認したいプレーを
映像でわかりやすく
全員が同じイメージを
持つことができるようにします
また 次の対戦相手の分析も合わせて
より効率的な練習ができるようにします
練習時間が短いのに
その大切な時間をビデオに使うのか
と思われるかもしれませんが
なんとなくの90分のトレーニングか
意思統一のできた80分のトレーニングか
をスローガンに
なんとなくこなしてしまう練習より
全員が同じイメージを描ける
練習のほうが ずっと効率的だと考えました
また 他校なら練習時間中に
納得するまでとことん話し合って
問題を解決できる話し合いの時間さえも
僕達にはありません
そこで 水分補給の時間を
プレイの振り返り 話し合う時間にしました
ここで重要なのが
「絶対勝つぞ」とか
「気合い入れて行くぞ」という
気合いを入れる
話し合いにしないことです
そうではなく 具体的に
次にどんなプレイをすべきなのか
という話し合いにします
この話し合いをより良くするために
GOOD BAD NEXT の
３ポイントを明確にまとめ
みんなの意識をひとつにします
ラグビーの試合中も トライの後
約１分間の話し合う時間があります
僕たちは 練習から試合を想定して
１分間で話し合うことを意識しています
この話し合いで
ポイントを明確にすることで
次にチーム全員が意識することを
ひとつにすることができます
ここまで 短い練習時間を
どう使うかについてお話ししてきました
ところが 今話してきたのは
他の人が３分で作るカップラーメンを
１分間に一生懸命凝縮して
作り上げる作業です
これでは時間が短縮されただけで
結局３分でできたものと
１分で完成したカップラーメン自体に
何の変わりもありません
ところが 僕たちは
カップラーメンを
１分で作り上げることの裏に
２分間も自由な時間ができたことに
気がつきました
この時間をどう使うかは 自分次第
ただ ボーっとしているだけでもいいし
考えて何か行動を起こすのもいい
そこで僕たちは ただボーっと
過ごしてしまうのはもったいない
そう思い この時間で
新たな一歩を踏み出し
カップラーメンを さらに良いものに
していくことを選びました
最も大切なのは この時間を
どう使っていくことなのかです
僕たちはこの時間を
主体的に行動することを意識しています
「主体性」と似ている言葉に
「自主性」というものがあります
違いがよくわからないかもしれません
しかし これらは似ているようで
全く違うものなのです
自主性とは 決められた課題を
自ら率先して行動することであり
主体性とは 何をすべきか
決められていないことを
自ら考えて行動することです
勉強を例にとります
家に帰って
親から何も言われることなく
自分から取り掛かる宿題が 自主性
家に帰り 宿題を早く終わらせ
余った時間で
この前の英語のテストで
英単語の意味がわからず
長文読解ができなかったから
この時間で英単語を勉強しよう と思い
宿題プラスアルファの
勉強をするのが主体性です
この主体性が発揮される場面は
主に２つ
通常の学校生活と 長期期間中です
通常の学校生活では
朝の始業前と放課後は自由に使えます
そこで僕たちは 委員会活動や
各教科の先生が開いてくれる
補習に参加することができます
受験が近くなった高校３年生の部員は
特にこの補習に参加する傾向があります
また この時間の他の使い方として
もちろん休養することもあります
僕たちはそれを
良くないこととは捉えてはいません
休むことで 休養時間を十分に確保し
疲労を回復することができます
部員たちは 良いコンディションを
維持することができるので
より多くのことに
チャレンジをすることが可能です
また 長期期間中も 自分で有効的に
時間を使うことができる期間です
僕たちはここで「成し遂げシート」
というものを使って
自分たちのセルフマネジメントに
磨きをかけています
「成し遂げシート」では
１日ごとのスケジュールや
１日の過ごし方を 表にまとめます
こうすることで
自分の行動計画が可視化され
より無駄のない
効率的な１日が過ごせます
そんな夏休みを過ごす部員も
やることは様々です
留学に行くことができたり
学校で行われる夏期補習に
参加することもできます
僕は この長期期間を利用して
３つの国に留学しました
各々が 苦手克服のために
取り組む夏休みは
僕たちにとって
とても重要な時間です
しかし この期間中に
体を動かさないわけにもいきません
合宿を最高のコンディションで
臨むためには
この時間でトレーニングを
することが不可欠です
あのプレーが苦手だ
こんなプレーがしたい と思ったら
自分に今 何が足りないのかを考え
そのための練習を行うなど
この時間を有意義に使えます
人が得意とすること
苦手なこと
優先して取り組みたいことなどは
人それぞれです
また たとえ同じ人でも
その時の状況によって
優先順位は違うはず
自分についてよく理解し
苦手を潰していけるこの時間を
ただなんとなく過ごすのではなく
全力で過ごしたら
なんて有意義な時間になるのでしょう
週３日 １回は最大90分
夏休みは１週間の合宿しか
練習がないという環境で
全国大会に出場するのは不可能だ
この環境ではできない
仕方がない と思うのは簡単です
こんなことを思うと
気持ちが楽になるかもしれません
しかし 気持ちが楽になっただけ
それも一瞬のことで
実際は何も変わっていないのです
自分たちにできることを
考えに考え 悩みに悩んで
工夫していくことにチャレンジしなければ
何も変わらないのです
「成し遂げる」
これは 僕たちラグビー部の部訓です
たとえ 90％の力を出したとしても
満足してしまっては
成し遂げたことにはなりません
与えられた環境を
100％活用することが重要なのです
僕たちラグビー部にも
まだまだ 工夫すべきところや
工夫できるところは
たくさんあります
皆さんも 様々な環境に
置かれていると思います
自分にとって 都合の悪い環境
周りと比べて 圧倒的に不利な状況
でもどんな環境でも 何かできることが
あるのではないでしょうか？
工夫できることが
考え 自分が変わることで
３分かかるカップラーメンも
１分でできるはず
そうしたら ２分間も自由な時間ができます
この時間を主体的に行動すれば
不利な状況なんて関係ありません
自分たちが置かれた環境を
最大限活用し
周りから不可能だと
思われていることを成し遂げて
新たな未来を切り開きましょう
（拍手）